[Music]
everyone is going absolutely insane I'm
not talking about the obviously insane
people like Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump but also the regular people in
your life like your coworker your friend
and your cousin we're all going
completely bonkers over this freaking
election people are losing friends
blocking family members on social media
and screaming at perfect strangers I'd
say we've hit rock bottom but with 60
days until the election I don't even
think we're halfway there yet maybe the
worst part about this election fiasco is
that nobody knows who to trust anymore
our mainstream media has failed us by
cozying up to the very people they were
supposed to be watching there's an
unholy alliance between members of the
media and politicians to never really
accomplished much of anything if you're
in the media the less you analyze and
the less you question the higher you'll
climb if you're a politician the more
you pander and the less you tell the
truth the more votes you'll get the Fox
isn't just guarding the henhouse but he
set up shop in there and he's selling
the eggs to the highest bidder of course
it's not just mainstream media that's
the problem here online media has in
many cases gone from refreshing and
necessary to discredited and
untrustworthy when everyone is reporting
on the news nobody is when everyone has
a website nobody does and when anyone
with money can fund another operation
that looks like a place of journalism
when it's really just a front for
propaganda well then we're officially in
trouble people often ask me who in the
news I trust and at this point I'm
really not sure who to say there's so
much noise out there coming at us from
so many different directions that
pilfering some truth out of the void is
almost impossible it doesn't have to be
like this nor was it always like this
but somewhere along the way we got
distracted by scandals and drama instead
of focusing on issues and reality plenty
of good people have tried to warn us and
tried to correct course but we didn't
heed their warning and now we're left
with a system that is chugging along
ight itself not because it's working as
it was intended to I'm not one of the
people who want to burn down the system
at all costs but if right now at this
very moment we can't recognize that it
sucked that something is very wrong then
is there any chance we'll ever wake up
all that said it's still pretty great
here in the US of A people all over the
world still want to come here to make a
better life for themselves and you don't
see many Americans leaving here to go
make a better life elsewhere despite how
nauseating this election is look how
engaged citizens are this country is
still a melting pot of people from every
corner of the globe who came here to
make a better life for themselves and
their children yes we have our problems
but most of the world would gladly trade
their problems with ours in the midst of
all this craziness one of the most
important things any of us can do is
figure out what we stand for as the old
adage says if you don't stand for
something you'll fall for anything and
maybe that more than anything else
explains our current political situation
nobody in government has really stood
for much of anything for the past few
years and because of that the masses
have now elected two of the least
favorable candidates in American history
Washington and Lincoln they are not all
the way back in nineteen ninety nine a
former pro wrestler and movie star named
Jesse Ventura ran perhaps the most
unlikely campaign in American history as
a member of the Reform Party he ran
against the Democrats the Republicans
and the system as a whole despite all
odds Ventura won the election and became
possibly the biggest outsider ever
elected to be governor in our entire
country's history though he left the
reform party after just a year in office
Ventura had a pretty successful run as
governor he lowered income tax / saw
several successful infrastructure
projects and perhaps most importantly
got new people especially young people
involved in politics unfortunately the
grind in the system did eventually wear
him down and he didn't run for
reelection in 2003 since leaving office
Ventura has been involved in politics
teaching writing and hosting a couple TV
shows most recently on my old home at or
a TV he revels in being politically
incorrect he calls out both sides and he
isn't afraid to go down the conspiracy
rabbit hole well I don't agree with
everything he says I love having voices
like his out there keeping the people in
power in check and challenging the
establishment narrative so my call to
you this week regardless of whether you
agree or disagree with Jesse Ventura is
to be a little more like him in one
regard don't be afraid to say what you
think and share your ideas in the public
square we need more people like you to
be outspoken now more than ever so we
don't only hear from the crazy people
it's not about whether you're right or
wrong it's about whether you're willing
to stand up and be counted otherwise
we're just going to let the inmates run
the asylum
[Music]
you
[Music]